is going to be the problem the people
that have been on birth control for 10
years
not every girl is these days and age
because it weighed us here yeah but then
they have how many abortions that's up
to them that is up to them so a lot
though it's a lot of girls
to be fair is it from what I hear from
them
they speak from experience do you think
that abortions like reduce the chance of
you having children in the future
especially does it depend on the type of
abortion or just abortions I think in
general some people I mean I don't know
that I'm not going to pretend to be like
a science like Superman
like this is okay okay when I was a kid
when I was a kid I everyone was getting
on birth control right and logically I
was thinking I just feel like if you
stop your fertility that's bad
I was never really like I was on it a
little bit but never really and I
remember all my friends were talking to
me like when I said this to them at like
16 17 whatever they they all were
looking at me like I was nuts and then
10 years later that we it [ __ ] with
your hormones it does all this stuff so
I just think logically like to be honest
I don't know if you're if you're taking
something that like kills the child
that's growing and yeah I just can't
imagine that's great I have mixed
feelings about that because there's so
many types of contraception in general
and birth control that is in the pill
every day is honestly very chaotic in
terms of how good it is for you in terms
of your fertility in the future but I
feel like it's there's so many like
advances in science in general that we
don't know how it's gonna like the
repercussions in general how it's going
to affect you so I feel like it's not
quite it's only experiment you know what
I mean and if taking birth control is
better if you and you know what I'm
actually pissed off about the fact that
there's so many like we should we could
spend so much time and so much energy
and so much money on birth control in
terms of adjusting men but we don't in
terms of what what do you mean adjusting
men as in them being responsible no no I
mean not just combination it's just
we have
have birth control that stops us from
releasing eggs or we have birth controls
that pauses the period or whatever but
we don't have birth yeah but the
emphasis is on the women why because
they're the one that's going to be
carrying the child so so that means you
because if anything obviously the guy
can can leave he can but might have to
pay some money
because nine months of pregnancy yeah
that's why I'm not talking about
pregnancy I'm talking about the like
conception but you're taking it to stop
pregnancy yeah but the men can also stop
because
we have all that we have all the power
like I'm sorry we have every Power when
it comes to not having a child yeah 41
forms of birth control yeah that's true
that's on TV abortion that's what I'm
saying right here there's so many forms
of birth control for the women yeah but
there's so few for men why there must be
a reason scientifically I'm sure there
is but I just don't know what it is
I think it has to do with with the that
we carried a child yeah because at the
end of the day yet he's right if they
leave I'm stuck with a big belly for
nine months going through every
trimester like it's not fair but life
isn't fair but at the end of the day
like they're not gonna carry the baby in
their belly so I feel like logically
when they started doing birth control
control they were like okay who's the
first person that is
yeah but I think she's trying to say
it's not just necessarily like people go
on it because they like their periods
are so bad yeah that it kind of like
balances or they have like too much
estrogen or something like that I don't
know I'm not on it for that reason but
is there anything is that is that is
there anything that would make you want
to have kids or would you like if you
met someone would you say it with chess
and say I don't want kids I've said it
before and it's quite funny actually
because you mentioned that the fact that
um a lot of women would like end up
alone if they told someone that they
were not didn't want children in general
I don't think that's true because I have
told people like if you ask me oh do you
really want I'm like no not really
because every man on here want kids yeah
majority majority in a very very small
stumble size like let's think about you
just said a small sample size because
you said the guy that I'm curious
guys I'm curious guys off camera does
anyone not want children from the men
anyone
okay
I'm just curious does anyone not like do
doesn't want kids is anyone saying yes
majority no I don't think maybe I'm in
the morning and that's completely fine
I'm probably just trying to sleep with
these yeah
it is what it is that's completely fine
but like I just I don't know
um I feel like a lot of people have
children because they feel like they're
supposed to rather than because they
genuinely want how old did you say you
were again I'm 23. so see one thing you
did say is that when you was 19 you you
was all over having kids no I didn't
that's not what I said I said I was more
likely to be persuaded into having one
child but as I've gotten older The more
I've learned the less I want children
okay the kids for life so you've got to
understand that one exactly like even
when you're 56 year old that is your
baby
that's my life as soon as you have a
child your entire life goes to the child
whether you want to or not and the thing
is if I had a child 100 I'll be [ __ ]
diverted to my baby but do I want to be
complete it's just it's just interesting
because cause like when people list the
reasons that they don't want to have
children you kind of admitted this early
on like it's why they say modern women
are selfish because everything's about
me me it's like I don't want to give up
my free time I don't want to give up my
job I don't want to give up my mind
but there's a problem being selfish if
you're not selfish and you and you
choose to be naive and blindfolded and
act like you can do everything and you
do a half-hearted job perhaps I I agree
like I agree with what you were saying
about the nannies like I'm not saying
every single person should have kids but
usually the people that don't have kids
I would say are selfish no you have to
be selfish you have to be simple I
genuinely disagree with that I'm sorry
that's really crazy being selfish for a
woman has a shelf life to be honestly in
a sense where like you can be selfish up
to a point but then you kind of gotta
make a decision in it like yeah
I couldn't have a kid with my life right
now I think which is understandable but
that doesn't mean like you still don't
have a shelf life on being selfish yeah
and I don't know I need you to elaborate
on shelf life and being selfish okay as
you as you said earlier um like
obviously there's a certain time limit
on obviously when a woman can well
possibly not sorry yourself then maybe
at a certain time limit on having a
child so obviously you can be selfish up
to a point but then sooner or later
you've got to kind of make the decision
whether you obviously want a child or
you don't so that's I agree you know
what yeah
I think if you if you've known from
young that I genuinely want children 100
if you want children to [ __ ] have
your babies like I don't mind that and
you know I mean like if you want your
baby if you want 10 kids have 10 kids I
don't mind that at all in fact I want my
friends to have kids I can't be an
auntie you know I mean you're scared I
don't want to be pregnant
of course I'm scared because you're
scared no it's not I'm scared but also
the responsibility that comes with a
child is so much for me I'm barely
functioning as a human being I do not
want to take care of another human being
as well and I'm not telling that's fine
I'm all about people doing what they
want to do I don't even think that every
single girl should have it there's a lot
of people that students have kids no but
I think the people that shouldn't have
kids are usually too selfish to have
children like you're just like you know
what some sort of scary thought because
you were talking about age earlier yeah
and you were saying what if you're 55
and I'm thinking yeah I want children
but let's say I wouldn't want children
yet and at 55 I'm home with 80 cats as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible